três rodadas de educação é a arma mais
poderosa é sobre isso que eu vim falar
um pouco sobre a minha vida não pode
mudar o futuro do nosso plano é saudável
2010 da universidade federal de são
carlos ufscar tem a oportunidade de
juntar as duas pesquisadoras então a
área de engenharia foi muito essa
palavra de ordem
eu poderia encontrar nada de
biomateriais 2012
o facebook radio mondiale no curso até
essa gradação da posse
ninguém envolvido em atividades de
pesquisa e do currículo também hoje
trabalha em um laboratório na a23 é e na
área de pesquisa e está desenvolvendo um
projeto para seguir como a gente vem
passando de nanopartículas
multifuncionais que o tratamento de
doenças cerebrais
ok então agora você deve estar se
perguntando o que eu pensei comigo
juntos em falar sobre educação
a idéia é que tive muita oportunidade
bacana
e é claro que o tio da sorte das pessoas
que atuarão nos quais se tem de
incentivar a área foi o cachorro abriu
muitas das minhas fotos foi poder ter
acesso à educação de qualidade um amplo
esforço pessoal
eu cheguei até a apresentação que fez um
pouco de si nas melhores universidades
do mundo que eu fizesse parte de uma
rede tão taxa da última apuração estudar
e também de muitas pessoas anunciadores
e muitos engenheiros e apesar de tudo
isso é muito bacana essa não é a
realidade de grande parte dos dois deles
hoje em dia não têm acesso à educação
que usam mais o time de qualidade
o brasil ocupa hoje um lugar e jorge
passou uma lista com 71 rica em
paisagens em sexto lugar no mundial de
competitividade de uma lista de 100 anos
a proporção de crianças que aprenderam
adequada um ponto as competências de
matemática até o final do ensino
fundamental é o ano do ensino
fundamental da rede pública é de apenas
11% equivalente parece a proporção de
crianças em português não é muito cheia
a proporção é de 23% equivalente a essa
proporção de clientes é quase isso
reflete nossa política na área social na
economia também
é nojo a achar que o desenvolvimento de
uma nação é de consumo de qualidade para
toda a gente tem diversos eventos de ti
no mundo e essa mudança não precisa
super bacana mostra legisladores da
educação
o nosso site os pesquisadores da fgv
isso dá um efeito de algumas cidades do
estado de são paulo que tem recebido no
final do século 19
alguns migrantes quebra média mas o caso
acabou por ser um local isolado esse
fator a chegada do evento a entender o
efeito disso no desenvolvimento da
cidade
eu tenho perceberam é que esse grupo de
pessoas e num dado maior investimento em
educação em uma área do conhecimento em
educação fez com que as taxas de
alfabetização e também foi feita na
escola um ritmo muito maior que as
outras a fazendo com que os mesmos
colares dessa cidade que tem também
muito grande sem vitórias - outra cidade
com esses resultados como esse é um até
hoje ou seja apresentada a educação foi
um fato bem moradores da travessa nova
geração que era uma galinha escolar é
cidade também tiveram um melhor
desenvolvimento econômico porque ela
chega uma melhor transição do modelo
agrário
leal exige mão-de-obra mais qualificada
bom foi realmente acreditar que a
educação de qualidade é a chave do
desenvolvimento do país
um grupo de amigos fuga num movimento
que tem como objetivo engajar o jovem
negou a indicação de qualidade aproximar
a sociedade do debate nacional a gente
jovem com seu poder de persuasão e
energia e um papel de alta 14 em
diferentes incidentes presidente da
educação e nações professores pedagogos
empresário realçou nada muito estudo do
grupo foi diagnóstico
ele revela casos de sucesso com o sobral
no brasil
ele sugere ações prioritárias eu tenho
uma visão de desenvolvimento do país
através da educação de qualidade
no ano passado a gente teve uma dimensão
do desafio do buraco de cerca de 50
convidados pois vamos poder executivo
quanto legislativo a compartilharem suas
prioridades é destaque nacional com
vídeos curtas eo popular
além disso nós somos responsáveis em
parceria com a base e com a fgv no rio
de janeiro para promover o único debate
nacional
ao falar em educação segundo turno das
eleições
esse debate aconteceu em um ano
são henrique país fala em 300 a
candidata à presidência a dilma rousseff
que também é secretária de educação
maria lina estava a imaginar estava
representando o candidato a esse método
pedagógico é transmitido online para que
façam as pessoas incluindo o brasil
também perguntas a 1
hoje nossos sonhos cresceu assim no
nosso time e nós somos separei as jovens
faz pelo brasil e pelo mundo
já os destinos é uma criança que cada um
de nós tem mobilidade e não conseguimos
conversar fazer com que o movimento tem
uma certa independência nas votações
uma das nossas principais ações atuais
cada esquina do bairro
a gente não foi uma pesquisa nacional
com lycra disponível no nosso site para
unir a moda jovem e ninguém contesta a
sólida presente quando a gente quer
saber se o jovem chef a educação como um
caminho vamos ações brasileiro tem sido
fundamental no ensino superior ies
públicas
além disso nós vamos realizar uma
companhia em agosto desse ano e na ásia
onde joga poderes forças projetos e
idéias para quem vai facilitar sua
mudança
a conferência tem três objetivos
principais o primeiro dele é formar uma
rede
um dos jovens interessados na educação
brasileira consegue o objetivo é colocar
no mesmo fala políticos empresários a
professores e jovens pedido de
impugnação como ele rebatendo
colaborando para criar um novo futuro
brasileiro eo terceiro objetivo e mais
importante é dar voz ao jovem a gente
quer dar um jovem capital do nosso país
e fazer com que ele seja com vida
bom as inscrições para a conferência
estão disponíveis até o dia 12 de julho
o eu te falar foi o formulário de
inscrição estão disponíveis no nosso
site
a gente não tem também uma página no
facebook que funciona como um canal com
passagens diárias e habitação e também é
resumo de artigos e notícias que vale a
pena compartilhar e ainda nosso time
a gente conta com um conselho e
apoiadores políticos são pessoas de
diferentes setores da educação no brasil
lula ajudou com suas experiências a
criar projetos cada vez mais inovadores
com cada vez maior de infarto na hora da
emergência o conselho usa produtos
turísticos vão atuar este ano na
conferência dança do bairro e
conversando um pouco com os jovens que
não a nossa personagem resposta aos
projetos em suas idéias foi passar um
pouquinho como vídeo agora que vocês é
curtinho explicando um pouco mais de
desafio à nossa pesquisa
ó
o que devemos fazer para que a educação
brasil deixe de ser visualizada momento
uma aplicação de edição mais de 100
bilhões educacionais no último ano e
realizou uma série de baixo durante o
período de eleições em segundo com a
gente vamos todos à para os jurados a
educação brasileira
junte a nova no próximo dia 29 de agosto
em brasília em passa à sua volta gritava
nós compramos passou como essa você nem
velho é um projeto inovador pode
melhorar a educação dos países um beijo
em geral você esteja ou a sua condição
financeira
não deixe de participar da conferência é
uma oportunidade nunca que você conhecer
outros já comparecem e tensão já
conhecia enviado em desenvolver na
capital do país uma platéia de
especialistas em educação o grande
iniciativa de pensar que não é falta
foi o que aconteceu o avião um twin
consignado para restringir as liberdades
foram feitas à noite já tiver acesse
www.portaleducacao.com.br oriental 13
pela distinção que reservou seis na
capital do nosso país
já discutimos o futuro brasil vem a cef
já o nosso site preencha também nossa
pesquisa nacional para que possamos
ouvir os seus sonhos da sua opinião
nós do campeonato de natação que estamos
nem o caminho deve ser tão valioso então
condições para cada nossas crianças e
jovens como o caminho do conhecimento e
aqui então acho que nossos parceiros que
nos ajudaram nesta caminhada estão com a
gente enfrenta um dos desafios caindo
por exemplo de um projeto super bacana
ver os nossos coordenadores que é o
carinho de quem marque os principais
portais educacionais do brasil de uma
olhada no site no livro muito legal
também não suportaria convidados e isso
é se juntarem a nós há muito foi uma
luta de todos
obrigado e depois de ponta